>> I NEVER EXPECTED THIS DATA BE
QUITE AS EMOTIONAL AS IT HAS
BEEN.
YOU GUYS --
>> ADAM, I DIDN'T EXPECT THIS
WILL BE QUITE SO MUCH, EITHER.
BUT IT MUST BE AN ADAM THING
TODAY.
>> Laura: THAT PATHETIC
DISPLAY SPIRITED DEBATE.
WHETHER REAL MEN CRY IN PUBLIC.
HOST OF THE MATT WALSH SHOW.
WHAT'S WRONG WITH MEN SHOWING
KIND OF THEIR SENSITIVE
VULNERABLE SIDE IN PUBLIC.
WHY IS THAT A PROBLEM?
>> I DO THINK IT'S BEEN
INTERESTING, I MENTIONED CRY IN
PUBLIC AND LOTS OF MEN HAVE
RESPONDED TO THAT STATEMENT BY
CRYING IN PUBLIC WHICH HASN'T
REALLY MADE ME RETHINK MY
ORIGINAL ASSERTION.
I THINK I'M BEING GENEROUS BY
SAYING THERE ARE SOME
EXCEPTIONS, IF A LOVED ONE DIES,
OR YOU COME HOME FROM A LONG
DEPLOYMENT, HUGGING YOUR
CHILDREN, YOU GET YOUR ARM STUCK
IN A WOOD CHIPPER, YOU'RE
WATCHING THE END OF THE MOVIE
"RUDY."
MAYBE I CAN PUBLISH AN ACTUAL
GUIDE AND IF A MAN FEELS LIKE HE
IS GOING TO CRY HE CAN CONSULT
THAT GUIDE TO FIND OUT IF IT IS
A SANCTIONED SOBBING FIT OR NOT.
I CAN POSSIBLY DO THAT IF I NEED
TO.
MY REAL POINT IS A PRETTY SIMPLE
ONE.
MEN SHOULD TRY TO CONTROL THEIR
EMOTIONS.
YOU COULD GO TOO FAR ON THE
STOICISM AND A BED AND RIGHT NOW
WE ARE AIRING ON THE OTHER
SIDE OF THAT EXTREME.
JUST TRY TO CONTROL YOUR
EMOTIONS AND NOT CRY ALL THE
TIME.
HE WILL REACT TO THAT, THOUGH.
IT'S ONE OF THOSE VERY
COMMON SENSE STATEMENTS BUT
PEOPLE REACT TO IT LIKE IT IS
ONE OF THE MOST INSANE STATEMENT
THEY'VE EVER HEARD.
THERE WERE GUYS THREATENING
PHYSICAL HARM TO ME.
I WASN'T REALLY WORRIED ABOUT IT
BUT IT IS A PRETTY CRAZY
REACTION.
>> Laura: THERE ARE SOME
REALLY TOUGH GUYS WHO
OCCASIONALLY JUST COME OF THE
OVERCOMES THEM.
ONE OF MY FAVORITES IS BRETT
FAVRE.
[SNIFFLING]
>> Laura: HE WAS RETIRING AND,
YOU KNOW, IT'S EMOTIONAL.
DON'T WOMEN, I'M THINKING, DO
WOMEN LOVE THAT?
MAYBE THEY DO.
HE WAS TORN UP.
HE WAS SO TORN UP, HE JOINED THE
JETS.
I'M JUST TEASING.
>> I WILL ALLOW THAT, IF YOU'RE
RETIRING FROM AN ATHLETIC CAREER
BUT DON'T RETIRE IN THE MIDDLE
OF A COMPETITION AS WE LEARNED
THIS WEEK.
>> Laura: HELD BY CRYING AT
YOUR DAUGHTER'S WEDDING, IT
SEEMS LIKE THAT WOULD BE AN
ACCEPTABLE MOMENT, HE IS?
>> THIS IS WHY YOU NEED TO
PUBLISH THE GUIDE THAT PEOPLE
CAN CONSULT.
I WOULD AGREE THAT IS ANOTHER
ACCEPTABLE OCCASION BEARD MAY BE
THERE ARE TWO OR THREE OTHERS.
>> Laura: ANOTHER OCCASION,
DON LEMON, QUITE FREQUENTLY.
>> WE'VE GOT TO SELF-RESPECT AND
INTERCEPT AND WE INTERVENE WHEN
YOU START KILLING US LIKE THAT.
>> I'M SORRY.
>> Laura: MET, THAT WAS NOT
WHEN HE LOOKED AT HIS LAST
RATINGS BOOK.
THAT WAS ACTUALLY HEARTFELT.
>> THAT WAS A MEAN COMMENT, THAT
MIGHT MAKE HIM CRY SOME MORE.
THERE ARE A LOT OF MEN WITH
FRAGILE EMOTIONS THESE DAYS AND
THAT IS WHAT WE A